well thank you for having me here Jared
it's always it's amazing these
conferences you're having is the first
time I've been here but the stuff you've
put together is just tremendous it's so
neat to see people I've never met before
firstly but also see a bunch of people
that I was talking with max that we had
met first in 2007 and in Iowa
Edu's are but a whole bunch of people
mark at DC it's just kind of this
community is awesome because it
continues to get bigger and it's just
the same people are also sticking around
it's it's a blast
so again yes my my name is Jeff Ryan
I've written at least a few packages
over the years actually I have no idea
where the clickers either yeah so the
first thing is first that every one of
my like 40 other talks I've ever given
are all technical this one is not
technical so we are either going to end
under time or over time and I apologize
for that so kind of brief history on me
all right
again Jeff Ryan I kind of think of
myself as principally a developer like I
like writing code I like solving
problems and I'd I don't have any
training in computer science have never
taken a computer science class which
probably shocks a lot of people who use
myself we're in industry but it's it
seems to work and for my current role I
actually work as a data scientist quant
for Citadel investments in Chicago which
is a very large hedge fund I'm working
on a quant desk and been there for five
years also as a shameless plug we are
always looking for super smart data
science people especially by a group so
anybody who's interested there's me and
there's also someone else here who might
be interested in talking to you so hit
me up on that and then the last part is
this artist thing which is funny because
I'm not really an artist not a visual
artist but what I like is that the stuff
that I I think of art is like creating
something that's not been there before
and kind of gets people to either think
or kind of makes a mark somehow
and software I'm good at software sort
of good at software so I kind of count
that as art but I also like art but
that's secondary
and then the art finance thing so Jared
pointed out it's a conference but it to
me it's far more than a conference
conference is this manifestation of kind
of a whole bunch of ideas that were
bouncing around I started writing qua
mod when I was trading myself I needed
some visualization tool and at the time
and are the only way to see to time
series together were to literally take
two windows like x11 windows and drag
them together and try and align them so
it's pretty disastrous and then I did
try ggplot which was brand new at the
time so no no no harm to ggplot but he
took so long to draw anything it was
surreal and again this is 12 years ago
but I remember going to get coffee and
watching a little bars print and then
coming back and I were still printing so
I had to buy it
I had to write something just to work so
that's where quantum AI was born in my
basement effectively with a co-worker
and and the next es kind of came out of
that but the conference is like I say it
comes after this need that this that all
I had and it turned out a whole bunch of
other people of Chicago that I ran into
who all also started writing packages
like dirt Gator beetle and the
performance analytics guys Bryan
Peterson Peter Karl and then Joshua
auric who is now the maintainer of my of
climate and xes whose co-author of XTS
as well but this is kind of weird group
of people that were all nearby and we
kind of got together and realized that
maybe maybe there's more if we work
together so it's not it's not bad
different than the tidy verse but we
just have like a different a different
mindset and we were not prescriptive per
se we collaborate and argue back and
forth then we try and make things work
together and I think we do a pretty good
job but we tried to build this universe
of things this community and the last
part with this kind of sequence system
which is getting at there are a bunch of
packages within
our finance space that do sort of what
you want and the weird part about
finance if anybody works in finance is
that you really don't care all that much
about making code that lasts when on the
outside I did because there's I just
wanted to be able to use it forever but
most of the time you are I mean you're
fighting against the market and it's
it's a really tough business to win in
so really getting things done and if
they work you never want to touched it
again so there'll be a part of the stock
that touches on that but but we just
need stuff that worked so that's that's
it and the success thing is kind of
goofy so again its first time I've ever
get this talk but success to me is not
like some sort of monetary success or
anything like that it's that this stuff
seems to have gotten kind of a life of
its own and continues to get bigger and
obviously this is giant but like the
auto finance space it's gotten giant
we're now in our tenth year of the
conference we have 300 people capped
other day I will also point out that I
don't come to New York very often but
it's remarkable how many people you guys
can squeeze in little rooms so okay I'll
move on to success is kind of this a
bigger picture thing I've got like four
pieces of this talk and they kind of are
broken down like motivation kind of
responsibility a community component and
kind of a marketing component all right
those are my MBA words I don't have an
MBA and but I do think their MBAs are
good if Jared Jared I think attest to
that yeah okay so first thing you are
not alone I live in the city I am told
these are stars that you can see but so
but it's a big world and even though
you're just one person it's probably
it's probably more than you the first
bullet here is kind of funny because at
our very first conference in the in
Chicago we had there was this our metric
suite of tools that was written by this
awesome guy who passed away two years
ago but it was called arm at our metrics
and he built this incredible suite of
software that was basically pegged off
of s pluses fin metrics so if but he
wanted to be able to teach his students
with X plus but couldn't afford it for
all the students and so we decided
because R was coming about he decided to
make a version like a clone of s plus
fin metrics in our and but he came to
the conference he and he was like I
idolized him mentor I convinced him to
come to Chicago and he gets on stage and
you know expect a great talk and gave a
great talk but at one point he just kind
of he stopped and he's just like he's
like why write software for me not you
and so it was like okay that was great
but his his point was he's writing for
his own purpose like he really wanted to
make the software work for him it was
not to be he didn't care about share and
he cared about sharing it but it was
only really because he needed his
students to use it and he liked that
other people not to use it too and he
built brilliant software and just a
great guy but but the point of that is I
used the software and I was not a
professor nor one of his students or a
student in student finance but didn't
use it in finance so it turned out there
are a lot more people using his stuff
than he ever dreamed of like he didn't
even care that we were using it which is
kind of what motivated the group in
Chicago to build additional tools
because he was very much focused on
teaching whereas we were focused on the
practical side that we really need the
things to work we needed him to be fast
and it's kind of a different mandate but
so yeah I guess the last or the middle
to there that kind of your your first
user oh I have one here your your first
user and you are your most important
user so don't don't let other people's
kind of opinions or directions influence
you that's another thing detail them
told me when I went out to Switzerland
with them and
kind of nicely took me on a boat ride
and walked around he was kind of and I
had built a package that was competing
directly with his and so he could have
tried to sink me on the boat but he he
instead said don't let anybody tell you
to not do this he's like this is
something you've made and stick with it
and if you believe in it just do it so
and this is XDS which ended up actually
kind of crushing his software which he
was fully onboard with like he didn't he
didn't care because again there's not
what he he cared about it hurt me
actually because I really liked him
stuff but that xes thing is funny his
right this also goes against a lot of my
talk you'll notice some internal
inconsistencies that's actually just me
but the time series thing so when I
wrote the time series classic came out
of quantum odd and the reason that came
out of Pont mod was I needed a way for
other people who used all these other
time series classes like TS mts all the
stuff in base our IR TSI TS FTS
resilient of these things and all of
them did something slightly different
and a lot of them didn't follow our
convention so they all kind of bothered
me a tiny bit but none of them were very
fast and then zu came in Adams who was
great so everyone you do but zu didn't
have time she would just ordered
observations Alice's ordered
observations which I know co-author of
or contributor to butters funny at the
time because like it just it didn't
solve my problem because I needed to
know was a time series object coming in
so I needed to be able to test it and
write all this stuff so I decided a sex
TS class would be able to take anything
you throw at it turn it into this
internal object that I could deal with
and then plot them and do whatever and
then give you back magically the one
that you gave it at the beginning so
like it didn't impact your workflow at
all okay I work with a high AR TS object
makeup pretty plot comes out as an IRT
NS object and nobody's the wiser what
happens inside so the idea was other
packages could you use this internally
to make a bigger user base better
software and that was actually what
happened kind of amazingly again I
surprised myself here a lot to the so
this thing is my friend Adam who's I
think hiding down a pole over there is
that pointed this out it's it's this it
happens to be lifted from Wikipedia but
it says Chesterton Spence thing which is
uh I guess
fairly well-known text bakers spaces but
again I told you before I'm not a tech
person per se but basically it's like
you they're just weird vents in the
middle of nowhere but it is just because
you don't see a reason for something
being there or being the way it is
doesn't mean there isn't a reason so and
the idea that I take from that is to
just sort of pay attention and really
look back and see what's been done
before and be careful not to rat what's
been done before so it's I do believe
you're publishing something you really
need to be responsible for what was
there and pay attention to API calls pay
attention to arguments pay attention to
syntax is abusive is our syntax might be
and like camelcase and dots and all that
other stuff it's like kind of the way
our is it's got to a million users just
like that I'm not thinking I'm good
enough to break it so morally or more
bored to the point is I I kind of needed
to solve or I wanted to solve and what I
think everyone probably also unsolved is
this like what's missing what what do
you need extra but don't mess with the
stuff that's there do the least possible
and that's a because I'm lazy but also
because you do the least amount of
damage if you're only touching a tiny
bit of stuff and the last three here are
there they repeat because they're so
important to me is that no one should
have to learn how to use your software
so Zoo inherited from TS TS was an order
is a is a regular time series and
irregular time series is kind of the
norm and the rest of the world unless
you're dealing with like econ data and
I'm act at a macro level so we needed an
irregular time series you solve that but
su solved it in such a way that it
preserved the way you constructed things
almost exactly even if the arguments
were named in silly ways that was just
the right way to do it so so you didn't
have to learn a new way or very very
little stuff you had to learn and then
xes subclassed Zoo to do the same exact
thing and then in the knee part is like
I got to then put the stuff back into
Zoo to try and make everything better
and
do even less damage I guess my side it's
not perfect there are many things people
can call me out on that I screwed up
many many things but that's kind of the
motivation this is also not a great
picture but I think this is the Second
Continental Congress but the and it's
also unattributed because there is no
attribution to it the idea here is like
I don't I don't want to tell anyone what
to do I just and I also don't want to
build anything so I don't like writing
code so one of the things was like get
as much that I needed to solve solve by
myself and try and get everyone else to
operate within the same constraints or
bounds and for that to work I kind of
broke it down where it's it's like the
UNIX way it's and I think and as much
the charity says I'm not on board a tidy
person I think and I'm not but but the
the the fitting together the stickers
are super cute by the way
but the pieces little pieces is great
like that is what you want and that is
it's awesome because then you get like
to take away there is you get
contributors who otherwise would have to
go through this horrible channel of
pushing or you know asking you sending
you a dip in the old days and I don't
like managing that so the fact that you
build something somebody can use it
there somebody contributed something
else is great and that is I think tiny
verse does that knocks it out of the
park and again the stickers are awesome
the two the two next ones I actually
couldn't again resolve myself to come up
with a simple solution err but you
definitely want to minimize dependencies
I certainly on core packages so like XDS
tries to be as minimally invasive it
only requires zoo because its subclasses
you it relies on zoo for a lot of the
methods that it uses it just does the
one thing ICS does that is different
kind of is it requires your index to be
time or zoo could be anything it could
be the names of animals and they just
happen to be ordered by whatever you
want and they can be
any wonder he wants and it'll always
work you can merge them together like a
cat times a cat you'll get the cat
answer the cat product but it is it's
not a time series so I needed a time
series but it only takes in zoo nothing
else the second part of that is
obviously if you want people to use it
you need reverse dependencies so I
encourage people to use it but also not
like I tried to do as least harm as
possible at the core level so when
somebody is using it they're not seeing
5 million packages roll into the screen
and clobbering each other and all of
that stuff which turns out to be
horrible and it's even worse when you're
doing something in production like data
exploration is fine you can swear all
you want for that but when you've got
something running for two years and
generating a signal and you're trading
on something and it may be not an R but
in any kind of language you don't want
to go I don't ever want to go back and
fix it and if something else a new
version of whatever XDS came out and
broke something that can't happen like
that it just can't happen so try and
minimize dependencies and then yeah this
the community thing goes back to the
ecosystem it's like you just want more
people on board so build to build a nice
place to hang out effectively and you'll
get contributors so and all the last
partner I feel like super ahead of
schedule the last part is is to be
helpful I thought this was funny J was
actually gonna make a QR code myself but
so and the be helpful is super super
duper easy users really matter even if
you're not building something that you
expect other people to use kind of like
detail them but but they do matter
people are great contributors whether in
you know highlighting that just screwed
something up on the documentation or
that you've actually implemented it
incorrectly but they are they are great
and you always need to be respectful of
them because they're you effectively
back to that first picture with the
stars like there are a lot of people
just like you it's basically you
complaining and you just don't have the
bandwidth to do all the complaining so
you have rely on other people to
complain but it works out really well
I like the idea to stay focused on one
thing so I kind of do the time series
stuff at this point but I don't want to
go too far you know out there with
something new though I will say since I
have an audience there's an EM map
package that I wrote that it's awesome
it does it's basically like it does with
FF and big memory do alright which Dave
gains somewhere around here but it's
very very little level it's like if you
know C code or if you know anything
about M map it lets you do this but
again in like the least invasive way
possible so you can use it and not have
all these crazy dependencies it doesn't
it doesn't do anything except for make
your life easier I think but dry it out
yell at me if it doesn't work and then
documentation I will stress
documentation I like handwritten
documentation I love the fact that are
made this process where you get this
horrible stubbed out Rd file and you
have to go back in and manually fix it
because it it makes you think about it
or at least makes me think about what I
want to convey and conveying it gets you
again more users more people are using
it correctly and then more contributors
and more users and more contributors and
then people showing up to conferences
it's it becomes this cool crowd that you
get to hang out with every year or twice
a year you run into them randomly in
different places and it's probably not
all about documentation but it gets
people on board it helps build this like
successful whatever that is and then the
next point is is users are really
important but they also have their own
agenda and they don't own your project
so don't don't really cater to them like
you can you could take guidance but not
all their suggestions are great
37signals I don't know if anybody knows
Basecamp put they're out of Chicago but
they're a very big project management
firm but they're not big they're like 30
people and the guys who run it are
fantastic but they they really have
always stressed building small anyway
I'll leave it but that is really it's
really you know be humble
talk a lot bad stuff maybe over time and
and just have fun make the stuff you
like have fun with it and try and
broadcast it and get more people on
board I think is it
[Applause]
you